melaye d'arc une première si vous aviez
le choix entre cinéma et télévision vous
mireille darc et personne d'autre
qu'est-ce que vous prendriez hong kong
atv mireille darc on peut dire que vous
êtes le mot n'est pas trop fort une
véritable découverte de la télévision on
est bien découverte découverte
bien que j'avais mairie d'arqués
franchement sublime à tel miracle ne se
produit que tous les 20 ans qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je trouve formidable pour nissan moi
bien entendu je pense quand même qu'à
défi formidable
à part moi on me découvre et on me juge
banques c'est-à-dire qu'on essaie tant
qu'homme veut démolir mais je trouve que
vous avez un petit côté provocant moi je
trouve pas ouais mais harry pourquoi
faites vous du cinéma parce que parce
que j'aime ça puis parce que je sais pas
faire grand chose d'autre et puis parce
que seulement là beaucoup de complexes
parce que j'interprète des personnages
qui ne sont pas tout à fait moi et je
veux faire des choses que jamais
j'aurais osé faire dans ma vie
mireille darc la célébrité ça représente
quoi pour vous pour moi eh bien je pense
que quand les élèves dans les écoles
écriront jeanne d'arc sans apostrophe
bien je pense que là je serai ces
lettres